shout out face jarvis though
man i just have okay i i have one more
speculation about that event
do you think some of those trainers knew
that those kids were going to lose so
they just like
trying to get a quick little quick bag
yeah probably all right i just i just
that's the thing is it
seemed pretty into it into it like
i don't know i just feel like you know
that that it's
it was kind of like a surreal shot
watching them come out like all dressed
up in their robes or whatever and
there's like a camp of like five
fully grown dudes behind them like yeah
into it i was like how do you
like i'm self-conscious about like like
getting
people to be into like what we're doing
i'm saying like
yeah how do you honestly go out there
and train for
a boxing match for the first time as a
social media star
and like not feel self-conscious about
the fact that these guys have been like
doing this their whole life
and they don't like how do they not how
do they not think that these guys don't
see them as a [ __ ] joke
i think the ones that were into it
it was like faze jarvis vinnie hacker
gibb austin it's like
it's probably like in the gym they see
the kid like ah this kid's got hands
and like to them like he's gonna win
because i think when you train at gyms
there's a certain sense of pride like
they're gonna turn out winners um i
like and certain gyms have a culture of
like if you're gonna train here you
gotta
you gotta beat like a certain level yeah
so it's like i think like at
to have like kept training whoever that
was to that point
i think that's why they can get into it
because they're like they have faith in
him they feel like they've invested a
piece of him
into it you get what i'm saying yeah but
i'm more saying like how do these kids
not have imposter syndrome like at all
like they don't have that at all i'm
sorry
they're just like i think the ones who
lost like did i've had that my whole
anything i do i have that right yeah
that's what i'm saying it's hard for me
to like
i just feel like all these people
i don't know they just like i'm
impressed by it i don't see them like i
know
that little self-awareness where it's
just like i'm gonna be a boxer now
and people are just gonna like
understand and help me out
no i no i completely agree with what
you're saying i think yeah
there's it was split i think for like
jarvis and the kids that were like gonna
go in there and do murder
it was just like yeah yeah they're not
even it's not even that they're a boxer
and it's for a tick tock event it's like
they
pre-staged they took a little bit of
blood and they put it under their nose
like smell that
yeah like here he goes we got this in
the bag
he's gonna win gonna win yeah but i
think yeah
for the other i think it's hilarious to
like
even you know all the shortcuts i feel
like they're taking
you know because to train at some of
these gyms and to have some of these
opportunities there's like boxers that
train every day that don't get to do
that [ __ ] yeah
and to like just do that and then be
like i maybe that contributes to it
you know it's like yeah oh i'm getting
all these opportunities i must be good
yeah but that's what i'm saying like how
do you not that that just
goes to not having any self-awareness i
guess yeah
it's like you can't be good you can't be
good at anything in six months
you can't be it's just not possible i
mean i i agree
i agree but i don't know
yeah i just i kind of i thought about
that after the fact like i wondered if
some of them would walk away from it and
like
now reflect on their experience leading
up and start to question the people
around them and think
damn was that guy just you know manning
me yeah yes man you mean like every time
i was hitting the pads was he just like
lying to my face and like
he set me up to like lose in there uh
you know um i think something that
you know it it was a it's a really human
moment was when taylor holder sat down
and his coach
was like really trying to give it to him
yeah like yo
what are you doing he's like you're not
doing anything we train
like you're letting him dictate the
fight you're not gonna win if you just
stand there like he's saying pretty
brutal stuff
and you could tell like taylor's just
like i can't i can't start
like that's a sobering feeling it really
is when you
like and thinking about all the [ __ ] you
said like yeah this guy's delusional he
wanted to fight canelo yeah it's like
when taylor said that i thought how do
you not realize
that the dude on the other side is going
to be a problem for you
that's the same as like believing in god
thing yeah you got to do on the other
side on a zoom call who's like
i can beat canelo i should be [ __ ]
horrified
that a dude says that without blinking
in his gamer chair
and you have to fight him in a month you
should be worried how he's going to be
in the [ __ ] ring
yeah i don't know but yeah it's a i
agree with you
i i i am impressed as well by some of
these kids that where they just
do this [ __ ] and they just no nerves no
nothing
yeah it i think it also sounds like a
brutal example for people because when
they watch that
they think that's how they have to be
yeah it's like no dude
you should be [ __ ] your pants yeah
for something like that yeah
exactly even 15 000 people in an empty
ass arena just walking into that arena
how do you not get nerves
you're like i have to damn yeah
i don't know it's a great it's a great
it must have been sobering though for
them like
especially for bryce hall yeah he's like
i'm a fighter i'm a fighter i'm a real
fighter
and then to get this bell rung like that
i mean and then
i thought it was just so crazy to like
say i've been in 40 street fights
dude they're professionals who don't
have that many fights like on their
tab that's like a crazy ass number how
do you even get in that many street
fights
like there aren't that many street
fights
for average person yeah 40
i think have you seen 40 people get in
fights in your life
okay at the risk of sounding like an
[ __ ] i think i
can genuinely say i've seen close to it
close to 40. close to 40. like in high
school or what
yeah through high school and like maybe
parts of college but that's not a street
fight
high school fights are not street fights
right i guess i can sit i mean
i guess they are i guess they are i
guess that's that's what it would have
to be for bryce
bryce hall he's 21 right yeah wait can i
i don't know if i told this story before
we just on the subject of high school
fights this is one of the funniest
fights i've seen in my entire life
this kid oh man i don't know if i've
told this before but goddammit it was so
funny
we got this kid this kid transferred to
our school and he was like
you know he had like twisted spikes he
had like a crazy ass look
everyone's like yo that dude seems like
kind of nuts
he got into this other kid who had the
presentation i'm kind of like a nerd
okay and they're about they get into it
they're about to fight
and the kid the transferred kid with the
twisted up here like pushes him he said
we can do [ __ ]
and the other kid still with his
backpack on falls into his friends and
his friends are like
[ __ ] get him dude and they push him
back and he uppercuts him like
clean bust his nose the kid with the
twisty braids is now like
bleeding from his face and he's like no
more it was like a one-hitter quitter
and the kid i think i think he had a few
follow-ups and they broke it up and it's
like he [ __ ] that kid up with a
backpack on
which is the funniest visual because the
other kid was like maybe like five
three yeah not to mention your balance
is so thrown so off dude
oh yeah that's 19 textbooks in your
backpack dog that's not what i'm even
you're right i'm not even incorporating
that much it wasn't like a slim backpack
he had like
like the full accordion like he was one
of these white fighting against you
yeah yeah your punch shouldn't be that
hard like it was the same sensation of
him like
being hooked up to a vest and like
dragging a fire truck
and for his friends to be like get him
dude i bet that push gave him like a ton
of momentum and he just went
here here's what i'm saying though okay
so you've seen you've seen close to 40
fights probably
okay i think the realistic number's
probably 20. 20. imagine being in
every single one and then
double that like
it's impossible you'd be so [ __ ] up
so [ __ ] up
40 and like especially in a street fight
dude because like if you're fighting on
like
pavement and other things you would have
like scars and some kind of like oh yeah
you'd have like a tooth like yeah it's
never growing back because some guy ran
my head into a tree
and i have nerve trauma in this eyebrow
so
that was in my 36th fight
40 street fights that number is
hilarious that's why i tweeted i'm like
i want to get booked for a trailer fight
so i can lie yeah the whole time
yeah i fought a thousand people
i fought five people at once and i
killed two of them
last guy i beat i went to his funeral
and i gave the [ __ ]
eulogy
i gave the eulogy the last guy and i
beat the [ __ ] out of everyone in the
front row
including his mom
[ __ ] with me [ __ ] yeah 40 is a
super insane number that's like that's
like
imagine okay that's like a month and a
half of care tops career right now
yeah he performs ever that's like being
in a street fight
every day for a month and a half
i mean dog if you've been in 40 fights
you would think you're at least decent
like he didn't cover up nothing
there's no fight iq in there yeah
yeah i don't know man i've been in one
street fight who
when i got my oh yeah that's right yeah
that counts dude
yeah i lost that fight i lost that fight
i didn't do [ __ ]
yeah i did not do [ __ ] i think i'm right
there with i took a
i didn't it wasn't a fight but i
definitely took it l i i had i
told the story before i got too too many
edibles and i like just talking to this
dude about moving his car because he was
blocking my friend's car
i was like oh this is your car this is
some crazy white kid he was like what
the [ __ ] are you saying dude
that's how high was is i would have made
no sense and it was like
offensive to him
what are you saying all he heard was
like me saying like my boy
can you move your shitty car yeah that's
what i said
dumb ass car because like my boy has to
move his car and like your car [ __ ]
sucks
[Laughter]
the only line i remember i'm like high
as hell and he just goes
tell your boy if he wants to come down
he can calm down
and i was like oh what he wasn't [ __ ]
that must have confused the [ __ ] out of
you as a high person
i was that high with like um yeah come
with calm down i'm done
calm down i don't where i am am i coming
down i'm coming down right now
grab him dude help me i'm coming down
man
i'm scared my heart's beating really
fast
get the [ __ ] off me full swim really
high
yo this kid's weird as [ __ ] you're gonna
leave me here i'm like really high
dude you're gonna leave him there that's
[ __ ] up
he was getting in my face i'm really
high
i'm really high let's beat this kid's
ass
so dude we can't beat his ass kyle he's
like
completely [ __ ] up my chest
can you die from weed dude can you die
from dude i think he's odin
i'm dying from weave bro give him mouth
to mouth
i don't want to [ __ ] do that that's
gay
he's gonna die dude do it quick
all right fine
all right fine gotcha [ __ ]
knocked out roll him on his back choke
him out
he [ __ ] thought it was high didn't
you yeah
you're gonna move your you're gonna move
your shoulders dumb ass bunk ass car now
bro
oh i forgot to tell you my boy is my
fist
[Laughter]
yeah okay